[Music]
[Applause]
you can watch NFL Network with Michael
Irvin on NFL Network's NFL game day
morning that'll be Saturday they start
at noon Eastern Sunday they will start
at 1100 a.m. eastern and the playmaker
three-time Super Bowl champ Hall of
Famer back on the program Mike good to
see you again uh could you have played
for Bill
bellich he I'm not going to let you
slide right on up in my DM like that
right there without saying how much you
miss me and you know how much I miss you
are you joking D come on man you know
it's so good to talk to you buddy it is
so good to talk it is great to see you
it is great to see
you listen I love I love bellich Che I
would have loved to play for bellich and
still could play if I could play for B
let me tell you why anybody DP that
wants to be the best at what they do and
try to to to win
championships yeah you know what bellich
chick is you know what he's about he's
about discipline he's about little
things those little things that will
surely help you win the championship
absolutely all right uh let me get the
question out of the way with the
Cowboys what should Jerry Jones do if
anything at the head coaching position
position this is a tough one you know
it's not like you went from and and I
guess that means you're a victim of your
own success it's not like you went from
eight win nine win snuck in the playoffs
and then lost then went to 11 wins
guiding the playoffs and and and and
maybe went a round in and then go to 13
wins you know what I mean that you saw
growth each year you came in 12 wins out
in the first round then did another 12
wins and you get out in the second round
then another 12 and you back out in the
first round it's about those big moments
if you're a player if you are a coach
and the 12 wins are great but if you
keep getting out you'll never get to the
final goal so I I just think I think
it's hard just to go into next year
selling what you sold this year to a fan
base who has done you who has waited
patient and thought man you can't get it
any better than it was set up this year
okay so what are you
doing so I I I I always believe that
hope dictate effort you know more hope I
got the more effort I give and and if
you take this in the next year you
you're giving the fan base less hope and
you can expect less effort you see what
I'm say because they're going to say why
am I investing all of my time and all of
my money when we know it's going to be
the end result that's what I'm worried
about so yes I think Jerry has to see
that and and and make make some
decisions on moving forward someone but
let's say you don't get
belich now are you gonna make the move
to make the move you're going to make
the move because I know the guy coming
in is going to be uh bring a different
culture than we
have well here is what you can call
fortunate for some unfortunate for
others there is a number of very very
very let me drop one more very one more
very good coaches out here so even if
you don't get ballot check there's a
rable there there other guys out here
that can help align you with the kind of
game and what I think you need here in
Dallas this is not a thing where I think
the Cowboys don't have the skill I keep
telling people why our business is
different it's not just about your skill
you're going up against another grown
ass man that's a grown man this ain't a
computer you punching you also got to
have the will you got to get your skill
in your will and you got to go up
against a man and some people have great
skill but not great will and and and you
can need a coach that can help deepen
that will and there are great coaches
out there that can help deepen your
will could you see Jim harwal getting
along with Jerry Jones
failure disappointment pain sadness it
it it it pushes a lot of jump to the
side you see what I'm saying about well
Jerry can't do with this Jerry can't
deal with that this kind of pain and
sadness yes you can you can deal with it
and let's be real Tim Harbaugh Bill
bellich all of them they got what we
call because they got that thing that's
common to all men three
letters e
G oh and what would it be like it be the
head co of the Dallas Cowboys how good
would that be for your e g oh stop
messing around yeah but I worry about
Jerry Jones's e
g what are you worried about don't worry
about Jerry Jones I need him to get out
tell you what you wor only worry about
Jerry Jones m o n
e that's what that he bring up the money
you you go get your egoo right because
you're the Dallas Cowboys head coach you
want to beat Tom Brady the Dallas
Cowboys will make your e g o right you
wanna beat Robert Craft your Dallas
coward and make your e g all right you
wanna beat the Patriots is the Dallas
coward the real America Team all right
your EG o up here that's all I said
Steve y u n g joined us yesterday and
Steve goes Jerry is the problem Jerry
Jones is the problem plus the players
are already Stars before they accomplish
something they're celebrities he said
that you should have the Cowboys start
the season no stars on the helmet you
get to 10 win wins you get one star you
win a playoff game you get your other
star he wasn't kidding you know I love
Steve you know how much oh here we go
love those boys you know I love those
boys he got we played in the grass
rolled around in the lawn all in Hawaii
I love his boy he call me Uncle Mike
they call me Uncle Mike but Steve tell
Steve to perpetuate that mess in 49ers
land don't shoot that directive nowhere
near the cowboy no no no no no I want
you to remember the ners are more
successful than the Cowboys
are well it depends on what we're
looking at right now yes they are right
now still in the playoff but ain't
nobody more successful than that brand
of the dollar I I agree the the brand
okay okay so okay so so so so now let's
so so when the S friend it's up here
it's up here it's up here it's high it's
high the other people might be down here
but it's high but when Dallas Cowboys
get up
here up here it's up here they haven't
been up there in 30 years Mike what
where they've been right here they just
hadn't been over the top in 30 years and
that's what we talking about right now
that's why you got me on because we
talking about what we need to do now
let's just be real it's only eight teams
left so they're what another 32 teams
out here that 30 teams out here
that 24 teams out here 24 teams out here
that still are home just like the Dallas
Cowboys right now so here's what you
gonna do Dan here's what everybody else
going to do everybody else is going to
start talking about oh it's just a
Dallas Cowboys nobody gonna talk about
them other 2014 that have got their butt
home too you know why because they're
not way up here what I'm but the Cowboys
this year were at home now I'm trying to
let y'all get some of this I'm trying to
let y'all get on the cowboy but if
you're GNA try to rip us up I got to
come back out with my
fist sometimes Mike you just don't fight
because you take the loss you got
knocked down you got knocked out you
were tyon against Buster Douglas you got
knocked out Mike you're looking for your
mouthpiece you got knocked out yeah
that's a do with I'm looking for
all right let's take let's take a breath
let's just take a breath
here take a breath take a breath that's
a good one
there I can't even come up I can't even
come up with 32 from eight 24 I'm so
Fring somebody last night said to me man
Mike I know I saw you crying all Sunday
I said jok I'm still crying what the
hell you talking about
um so when it's all said and done who's
going to be in Vegas with these teams
man it looks like it's going to be the
color of that logo that people be
talking about that purple red honestly
that that purple and d r or whatever San
FR is and Baltimore but now this is
interesting because the these young guys
don't know what they need to know and
Man Dan listen man that D see
St that that that dude right there joy
and love yeah those are two young
dudes that's going to create habit this
weekend I mean they're going up against
a tough challenge but but they'll be up
for the challenge and that and each one
of those kids can rise above the system
you know you can get you can get Miami
with that with with what s FR did and
but but but you but you but you can't
this kids can rise above the system even
if you get S friend St your in love they
can rise above the system do you have
anything interesting in your office
there I don't see any awards any there's
no Hardware in there what's what's going
on well what what man listen man I I
keep telling my lady get all this stuff
out of here man I said when you win one
ring or one Super Bowl then you got to
keep it back better remind people but
when you got as many as I had they know
you have them get all this stuff out of
here I got more rings and Super Bowl
championship you see College
Championship enemies all this get all
this stuff out of here you know I have
them man we don't need to put them back
here but but she said she she said you
you the m just go get the money don't
say nothing else that's all you do so
I'm just the m d that's all I do I go
plow the land hey what do you plow the
land what do you what are you what are
you doing with uh stunt did you start a
uh a social media app
oh yeah yeah stunt said let me D you
know you know you and I we go a lot of
places we've been a lot of places D you
know some kind no no no we haven't been
in Wild places we've been a lot of
places I said wild plac but a lot of
places we weren't in a while no no wait
wait don't don't act like that D don't
make me stop no no I wasn't there in the
Mike make me look skirt a little bit now
I wasn't there in the 90s I wasn't there
with don't make me look that skirt a
little bit now we were out there it was
Jacksonville but we were out there in a
wild place in Jacksonville back in I was
at I was at the club not du Club
[Laughter]
Mike I was at a club not D Club forget
don't forget that D that was the funnest
thing we've ever had yeah hey I know we
doing this in front of people listen we
went one night Sunday night we got the
Super Bowl it was cracking it was hot it
was beautiful beautiful crowd we came
back man let's go back that place
sometime toward I was the only white guy
in there that night yeah that crowd was
different this crowd is darking up
so I'm like Mike I I I'm gonna ask for a
light beer is
that I said D you got SW you good buddy
you good you got they like you D you
good the brothers kept saying I got
cable man I know who you
are oh my God oh my
God
okay that's great that's one of the
greatest times I've ever had man D we
had such a good time that night with all
them brothers around
I I just kept trying to start stuff what
you said I them brothers I
just I sat at the bar and I just nursed
my beer you know and Mike is trying to
think say I'm saying things about other
people in the bar what did you say about
them and I go Michael stop it stop it
what did you say about them DP and like
go I didn't say
anything
oh my God oh my God oh God that was so
much F oh you know what maybe we'll do
it in Vegas Mike I never forget that we
gotta do it
again hey you know I love you buddy that
was a good stuff great to Great to talk
to you it's always good to talk to you
we gonna get back right there we gonna
get it back right worry get
a thank you Michael that's Michael Irvin
that's the
playmaker yeah he's like d we did Sports
Center and he goes come on we got to go
out we're in Jacksonville I goes where
are we going he goes I got a got a place
got a club walk in you know not a lot of
people next thing I know about an hour
later packed I said Mike I'm the only
white guy in here goes D it's okay it's
okay said all right I sat at the bar I
think I had a Miller
line I don't think I moved just like I
I'm good right
here let me take a break